barely moves but suddenly he shifted
back in his chair and
yeah if he spotted this knight check he
knows that he's about to lose yeah
and it's on the board there was never
going to be any doubt wesley of course
he's one of the finest players in the
world
he's going to spot a tactic like that
pawn takes the rook slides across just
as david indicates
and uh unfortunately i mean is there any
hope
with in blocking that check with the
bishop black throws his bishop in the
way then white bishop actually at the
bottom of the board can go up and
capture that black pawn
on h6 again and that black bishop is
just
it's just a stop gap it's gonna get uh
it's gonna get lost at any moment so
liam he's what's he gonna do is he gonna
resign and wesley found it the first
time he found it in game one but he
found it again and
that's why the top players are so good
they do go back to basics
quite often and they think checks
captures and threats and white's ki
winning move the killer move on both
occasions was a capture
and it was a check that's why we look
for them on every occasion if they work
they can be this powerful they can just
destroy the opponent's king position and
yeah liam he's lost in the same way
twice now today
that's going to be painful the king does
go to the side and now white queen's
going to
jump forward yep and no way
i mean is there any way to defend
against checkmate i don't see it
you could throw the queen in the way but
you know the black queen if it comes out
it's just going to get captured by
white's bishop so
it's all going to happen now this
checkmate next move on the g line
you have to there's literally no other
way other than to get put your queen in
uh and just give up the black queen for
a bishop now
liam he'll either resign or give up his
queen and either way
i think he will just resign it will and
it will be
game over very what a painful day for
liam
i mean two careless moments and he's
just
thrown away the match yeah exactly
and in the same way both times that's
the that's the
that's a real uh yeah tough thing to
handle
but wesley meanwhile just waiting for
that resignation and it comes
up wow after only three games in the
first
final match it's over wesley so winning
both of his games with the white pieces
liam just disappearing uh